- WOODY, I HAVE THE RESULTS
OF YOUR COLONOSCOPY.
- BE HONEST, DOC.
DO I HAVE THE ASS CANCER?
- I'M NOT GOING TO SUGARCOAT IT,
WOODY.
I FOUND SOMETHING ALARMING
IN THERE.
- NO!
[alarm clock ringing]
OH, YEAH, I ACCIDENTALLY
SAT ON THAT.
- REALLY?
THESE TOO?
LOOKS LIKE SOMEBODY FELL
ASS-FIRST INTO A YARD SALE.
- I JUST LIKE TO BE ORGANIZED.
I CALL IT BUNG-SHUI.
- BESIDES SOME MILD TEARING AND
WHAT I SWEAR WAS AN OOMPA LOOMPA
THAT I WAS NEVER QUITE ABLE TO
GET A HOLD OF, YOU'RE ALL CLEAR.
- GREAT.
NOW, IF YOU'LL KINDLY
RETURN THOSE THINGS TO MY ASS,
I'LL BE ON MY WAY.
- OH, WOODY, YOU'RE STILL
UNDER THE INFLUENCE
OF THE ANESTHETIC.
I CAN'T LET YOU DRIVE
YOURSELF HOME.
- I GAVE YOU A BUNCH
OF EMERGENCY CONTACTS.
DIDN'T YOU CALL 'EM?
- YES.
I GOT FOUR WRONG NUMBERS,
THREE HANG-UPS,
AND A "[bleep] MY MOTHER."
SHE'S BEEN DEAD FOR THREE YEARS,
SO THAT WOULD BE DIFFICULT,
BUT NOT IMPOSSIBLE.
- OKAY.
SO WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
- MEDICALLY SPEAKING?
WELL, YOU HAVE NO FRIENDS.
AND SINCE THERE'S NO ONE HERE
TO PICK YOU UP,
I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO PUT YOU DOWN.
- WAIT, WAIT!
CAN'T I JUST CALL A CAB?
- HMM, I NEVER THOUGHT OF THAT.
GUESS I DIDN'T NEED
TO PUT ALL THOSE PEOPLE DOWN
AFTER ALL.
BOY, IS MY FACE RED.
KIDDING!
I CAN'T FEEL EMOTION.
- GET ME OUT OF HERE!
- TOMMY!
SHUT UP AND PLAY YOUR TROMBONE!
[sad trombone plays]